yeah I've got really really great news  for you all okay it is girl Girl Scout  cookies oh man oh  even New Year's resolution whatever  whatever cookie raspberry rally What  It's Like The Thin Mint but it's infused  with raspberry flavor it's only online  though so get your fingers warmed up and  hop online to get that cookie the rest  of course you can get from your friendly  Girl Scout at the store or at your I  don't know at your office yeah  everybody will be doing them um of  course those will be  um for sale very soon so this is new  raspberry rally they seem to be coming  up with a new cookie every year now yeah  I I think raspberry rally technically  came out last year because I'm pretty  sure I ordered it but for some reason  because of the supply chain they  couldn't get it but it looks like it's  here the raspberry monster okay with a  raspberry yeah